now to some very exciting news about a
planned SpaceX flight for a man who's
already pushed boundaries in space 21
years ago American businessman Dennis
Tito was the first person to pay to go
to space his mission to the
International Space Station lasted eight
days now 82 years old Tito plans to go
back to space with someone very close to
him and travel even farther than before
first on CBS mornings Tito spoke with
Jenna shamlin about his new Mission and
who he's bringing along
he was the world's first space tourist
California millionaire Dennis Tito is on
his way to the International Space
Station he blasted into orbit earlier
this morning aboard a Russian rocket
Dennis Tito dropped 20 million dollars
on a 2001 trip aboard a Russian soyuz
spacecraft
he glided through the hatch of the
International Space Station wearing a
Russian cosmonauts uniform and a
delighted grin called the most expensive
vacation in history it was Paradise
Paradise I just came back from Paradise
I've been thinking about it every day
since now Dennis Tito is vowing to do it
again we met the retired businessman and
his wife Akiko at the SpaceX star base
facility in south Texas where he
announced he intends to go back to space
this time with SpaceX and taking Akiko
along for the ride a week-long flyby of
the Moon did they propose it to you I
brought it up you said can I orbit the
Moon please that's what I'm interested
in I will not go back to Earth orbit
I've been there done that their ride to
the Moon spacex's Starship rocket when
you guys look at this like what do you
think
is amazing it's off the chart when
Starship is hoisted atop its super heavy
booster it will be almost 400 feet tall
33 engines firing that blasted off the
launch pad twice as powerful as NASA's
Artemis Moon rocket
Starship designed to be fully reusable
is still in development SpaceX has
nailed some test flights others erupting
in fireballs
what gives you confidence this is going
to work every time a rocket explodes
you'll learn something
so the more rocket explosions we see the
better
because then we'll get all the bugs out
of it realistically when do you think
you'll fly
I take the worst case
five years
that would put the California man close
to 90 years old 82 now he says he feels
great I am probably in better physical
shape
than I was 21 years ago Akiko Tito is a
commercial pilot who like her husband of
two years says she's always been
interested in space I'm Gonna Make It
Happen together as a couple you were all
on board you had no hesitation I have no
hesitation not for a minute no for a
minute Tito's flight would be the second
Starship lunar flyby the first book by a
Japanese billionaire 10 other yet to be
named crew members would join the Tito's
myself being in my early 80s will be
very inspiring to people of all ages
because
they'll now be able to start to think
about their golden years
and maybe it's not going to be a rocking
chair
maybe it's going to be a rocket ship a
rocket ship after shelling out 20
million for the last trip Tito won't say
how much he's paying for what he's
calling a post-nuptial vacation we got
married during uh
so we didn't have a chance really to
have a honeymoon
so maybe this is our honeymoon for CBS
mornings Janet shamlian at SpaceX stir
base in South Texas